bonsoir merci pour l'invitation
je voulais commencer déjà par rendre un
hommage à mon directeur de thèse de
neurosciences qui a beaucoup étudié donc
ce circuit de la récompense qui est
décédé il ya un mois voilà donc c'était
un des premiers chercheurs dans le monde
en france à mettre des gens dans des
scanners pour aller regarder qu'est ce
qui se passe dans le cerveau
quand on a un désir sexuel qui a étudié
l'excitation sexuelle au niveau des
voilà donc c est donc c'est donc vous
allez voir que l'entrepôt on va en
parler de ce circuit de la récompense ce
circuit du plaisir donc le thème
d'aujourd'hui c'était vivons nous dans
une société addictogène alors pour
commencer je voulais vous montrer cette
photo donc par exemple cette photo pour
une pizza 1 si on lille ce qui est écrit
sur la pancarte s'écrit new conforte
york running et le craving vous allez
voir c'est un terme hyper présent en
indique tour c'est ce nouveau terme le
crédit dont je vous le redis finirait
tout à l'heure ensuite j'en vienne nous
parler de ces nouvelles addictions ses
addictions aux écrans donc j'ai regardé
un petit peu sur youtube
finalement dans le monde toutes les
minutes c'est pas plus de 4,8 millions
de vies des deux de vidéos youtube qui
sont téléchargées
c'est toutes les minutes il y à 2,2
millions de snapshot
alors moi les snapshots je connaissais
même pas ce que c'était en fait mais
j'ai ma nièce qui a 15 ans donc il est
natif de cette nouvelle ère l'ère du
digital et elle a pris une photo comme
ça est juste un écran noir
je dis mais qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
ça sert de prendre une seule non non
c'est juste pour envoyer en fait pour
faire un snap parce qu'en fait le but
c'est à envoyer un maximum de photos on
s'en fout de la photo en fait ceux des
écrans noirs juste pour avoir des
flammes parce que l'idée c'est d'avoir
de plus en plus de flammes
bon ces nouvelles voilà notre nouvelle
société j'ai dit ok donc voilà donc on a
tous maintenant dans notre poche 1 ce ce
que j'appelle finalement ce doudou rétro
éclairé c'est notre smartphone c'est
notre petit doudou un conte va même
aller à mener des fois jusque dans notre
lit donc ce doudou
eh ben c'est 80 fois par jour qu'on va
les activer désactiver 80 fois par jour
c'est quand même énorme
et à chaque fois c'est pas plus on reste
il nous faut 25 minutes pour retourner à
notre activité
donc tout a été fait dans cette société
pour effectivement capter notre
attention parce que maintenant il ya une
économie de l'attention et l'idc bapu on
va rester sur ces sites sur ces réseaux
sociaux plus ça va rapporter des sous
humains
morgane nous on a bien parlé de cette
nouvelle ère l'ère de l'industrie
la quatrième révolution industrielle
donc ce ce nouveau doudou il va falloir
qu'on apprenne aussi à vivre avec
parce que je pense qu'on va pas pouvoir
s'en séparer comme ça mais est-ce que
nous sommes tous pour autant addict ça
c'est quand même une grande question
parce que l'addiction c'est une maladie
donc voilà cette image de ceux de notre
nouvelle notre nouveau doudou qu'on
amène dans notre lit alors pour parler
du circuit de la récompense les premiers
les pionniers avoir découvert ce circuit
la récompense est old côté miller dans
les années 1950
en fait ils se sont rendus compte qu'en
mettant des électrodes au niveau de
l'ère tegmentale durera certainement
talent ventrale le rat il a la puissance
arrêt sur la [ __ ] sans adresse en
soirée et en fait ça faisait quoi ça ça
faisait se crée t de la dopamine cette
hormone du plaisir au niveau du noyau
acument donc c'est comme ça qu'a été
découvert le circuit de la récompense
et c'était même à la fin compulsif le
rat il oubliait d'aller s'alimenter
d'aller manger d'aller dormir donc ce
circuit de la récompense c'est celui-là
c'est sur le circuit qui va partir de
lartigue mentale mental qui va aller
jusqu'au noyau accumbens pour faire
secret tu es de la dopamine est là la
dopamine c'est ce qui va renforcer notre
désir mais ce circuit il n'est pas
pathologique en soins il est même on en
a besoin de circuit de la récompense
parce que ben justement pour pour se
reproduire pour manger pour boire on a
besoin de ce circuit est par contre les
nouveaux ingénieurs de des réseaux
sociaux ils savent bien ils connaissent
bien ce circuit et s'en servent pour
justement nous faire cliquer de plus en
plus sur les sites etc
pour parler aussi dans les addictions je
voulais vous donner un autre exemple
c'est l'histoire du conditionnement ce
qu'il faut bien savoir c'est que des
fois il n'y a même pas besoin d'avoir la
récompense pour se traiter la dopamine
syrien d'anticiper la récompense ça va
nous faire secrétaire la dopamine
d'accord donc ça va susciter ça me crève
hindu les affiches au départ ça va nous
faire secret tu es de la dopamine rinck
de voir l'image de la pizza on a envie
d'aller manger cette pizza en secrète la
dopamine en avancées pour prendre cet
expert pour expliquer cette expérience
ces expériences du chien de pavlov sais
pas s'il y en a parmi vous qui
connaissent donc c'est une expérience ou
au début ont fait sonner une cloche
le chien mais y'a pas se passer grand
chose qu'on fait des sonner une cloche
c'est pas un stimulus récompensant c'est
pas très intéressant
par contre si on fait sonner la cloche
et en même temps lui amène une assiette
à manger voilà comme il voit l'assiette
à manger claque activation du circuit de
la récompense donc secret sion de
dopamine et on répète cette expérience
cloche assiette à manger cloche à cette
manger donc on conditionne et à la fin
quand on fait juste sonner la cloche et
bien le chien il va saliver quand même
parce qu'il est associé à la cloche
l'assiette à manger et ça dans les
addictions c'est un mécanisme qu'on
retrouve souvent moi je prends toujours
l'exemple pour mes patients pour la
cigarette la cigarette on la salive la
cigarette après leur part quand on monte
en voiture si on a l'habitude de fumer
en voiture et là on va saliver aussi eu
l'idée de cette cette récompense on
salive en avance donc ça c'est très
important
c'est ce qui va susciter aussi chez nous
le craving donc voilà la diction qu'est
ce que c'est finalement la diction c'est
la rencontre d'un produit d'une
personnalité d'un moment socioculturel
donc là c'est sûr que notre société
elle est addictogène donc le moment ce
sens culturel
là ça joue ainsi on est sur une île
déserte
s'il ya rien du tout qui n'apparaît pas
de y'a pas de quoi susciter de
l'addiction il ya peu de chances qu'on
développe une addiction
ça c'est sûr par contre si temps si on
est dans une société très addictogène
comme c'est le cas actuellement pour
développer la diction il va falloir
aussi qu' elle ces facteurs de
vulnérabilité et aussi en fonction de
l'individu est un des points forts
d'addiction pour parler de la maladie
addiction c'est cette notion de perte de
contrôle c'est quand on a perdu le
contrôle qu'on a perdu la liberté de
s'abstenir
c'est plus un choix l'addiction c'est
qu'on est plus dans le choix donc la
diction c'est ce processus par lequel un
comportement qui peut fonctionner à la
fois pour produire du plaisir et pour
soulager à me les intérieurs et utilisé
soit un mode caractérisée par l'échec
répété dans le contrôle de son
comportement et la persistance de ce
comportement en dépit des conséquences
négatives significative donc qu'est-ce
qui va expliquer cette perte de contrôle
il va ailleurs deux facteurs importants
il va y avoir la vulnérabilité
individuel dans parmi les vulnérabilités
individuel il le fait par exemple
d'avoir été abusés sexuellement dans
l'enfance comme j'avais facebook matelas
dessus moi j'avais retrouvé beaucoup
effectivement quand on a eu une
maltraitance sexuelle
on a cinq fois plus de risques de
développer une addiction derrière c'est
énorme
et puis il ya le temps d'exposition
c'est sûr encore une fois c'est pas la
même chose
plus on va être exposée jeune plus on va
être exposée ça ça va être plus à même
de développer la diction donc ce risque
addictif faut bien tenir en compte ces
trois paramètres à la fois l'individu le
produit ou le comportement et le moment
à laquelle ça arrive et on passe pas
l'addiction c'est un processus qui est
long c'est donc la maladie on passe de
l'usaj simple donc là où on peut avoir
le comportement peut aller sur nos
smartphones on peut aller mais
s'équilibre et la corse et à côté de ça
on continue à avoir un travail nos
loisirs
tout est bien équilibrée et après il
peut y avoir un usage de plus en plus et
c'est que c'est excessif
en fonction de nos vulnérabilités en
fonction de l'environnement dans lequel
on est et là ça commence empiéter sur
des sphères et la diction voyait c'est
la dernière boule à la fin c'est qu'on
ya plus de ça il ya plus rien d'autre
encore
donc c'est ça la diction donc est ce que
vraiment on est tous addict je ne pense
pas je ne pense pas qu'on soit tous
addict à nos téléphones
c'est sûr qu'on a un fait un usage
excessif mais de là à parler d'addiction
maladie moi personnellement j'en vois
plus en consultation des addictions aux
écrans peut-être que ça va arriver parce
que peut-être que comme c'est un
processus qui met du temps à se
développer
peut-être que je veux en voir dans dix
quinze ans voilà ce risque addictif
cette interaction entre le produit et
puis alors on a vu aussi dans le produit
ce qui est important c'est les flèches
tout l'effet rapidité et morgane nous a
bien dit que nous sommes dans une
à l'ère où tout est rapide tout c'est
une société de l'hyper offre de l'hyper
intense de l'hyperconsommation donc ça
ça va jouer parce que par exemple le
tabac il n'y a pas plus addictif que le
tabac sans pansement que c'est après
c'est pas vrai mais si le tabac c'est
addictif pourquoi parce que quand on
prend une bouffée de cigarette
le shoot de nicotine il est très intense
mais surtout il est très rapide c'est
cette seconde la forme inhalée
elle est plus rapide que la formule est
qu'un shoot d'héroïne qui lui va mettre
plus de temps donc ce côté de la
rapidité à une importance dans le
développement de l'addiction les
facteurs durabilité et les facteurs
d'exposition et donc secret vignes qu'on
a vu sur la première photo secret vignes
qui est cette manifestation clinique la
plus caractéristique de l'addiction
c'est cette envie irrépressible de
consommé une substance ou un
comportement gratifiant alors qu'on ne
veut pas à ce moment là donc ça c'est un
interne
voilà tout est fait dans notre société
aujourd'hui pour susciter ducret ming on
nous met des images on nous nous colle
plein de choses pour suspects selon lui
mais le plus important c'est prônons du
contrôle ayons un contrôle sur ça et
donc il faut à falloir éduquer aussi nos
enfants avoir un contrôle et du coup par
exemple dans les mesures qui a été mis
pour les écrans pas d'écran moins trois
ans ils ont etc
c'est pour aider à apprendre il faut
éduquer faut qu'il y ait un contrôle
faut qu'on apprenne aussi à nos enfants
à développer leurs habilités
psychosocial parce qu'on tombe pas dans
les addictions par hasard l'addiction
c'est souvent quand il ya une souffrance
hausse est sous jacente c'est une
maladie mais c'est que c'est quand on se
sert d écran parce que finalement on a
une phobie sociale qu'on fait plus rien
d'autre que sur ses écrans donc là on va
être plus à risque d'être dans
l'addiction maladie mais si toutes nos
habilité à côté se sont bien développées
c'est pas le côté usage excessif qui est
embêtant c'est vraiment quand il ya plus
rien d'autre à côté
voilà donc j'espère que vous serez
convaincu moi personnellement maintenant
j'ai enlevé le téléphone de la chambre à
coucher
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]